We're trying to figure out what the running time is asymptotically Θ
for selection and insertion as a function of n and K and then we can substitute in the value of K.
If there's n elements in our list and we're interested in the top K,
what the selection algorithm does is it goes through the elements one at a time
and for each of these n elements it tries to figure out where in this list of K it needs to go.
For each of these n, it does an insertion or a selection.
Okay, let's do insertion first. It does an insertion in this list. That insertion takes Θ(k).
It's basically running through this list, figuring out where the value goes,
sticking it in, and shifting everything else over.
The insertion algorithm is going to take n times that for a total of Θ(nk). Now, selection is the same.
What happens in selection is you run through this list of n,
and you pull out the maximum and delete so that takes Θ(n)
and you repeat that once for each of the elements you want to pull out.
It becomes also Θ(nk).
Sorting on the other hand sorts this entire list, which I said before was n log n.
Then, well, it's kind of done at that point but you could imagine also looping that through
like the first K elements but we basically have them at that point
and K is smaller than n so asymptotically that's the whole running time.
Now, if K is n/2 that's n times n/2 where n².
This is Θ(n²). This is Θ(nlogn). We're much better with n log n.
With the very long list that were wanting to tap values of,
you might as well just sort the whole thing.
√n, well what happens with √n? √n where look we're comparing n log n to n(√n) which is n³/².
n³/² is asymptotically larger than n log n so we're still better off just sorting the whole list.
Now, let's go to the other side of the spectrum. What if there's 100 elements in the list?
Well if K is a constant, K is 100. Then the big theta of this is just Θ(n). It's a linear time.
So linear beats nlogn. So we'll definitely want to choose these algorithms
over sorting if it's a small number of elements that you want to know.
loglogn is similar. We end up with n(loglogn), which is better than nlogn.
And finally I guess it'd be kind of obvious at this point if we substitute logn in for K,
we have nlogn for selection insertion but we also have nlogn for sorting so they're actually the same.